magical creatures will feature
prominently and a number of them have
already been confirmed including
centaurs goblins grab horns moon cats
spiders trolls and hippogriffs the
official trailer even shows we'll be
able to ride hippogriffs cats and owls
are also shown in the trailer although
we don't know for sure about toads just
yet as for the more nefarious creatures
both inferior and dementors will make an
appearance and there's also this
enormous dragon if you look carefully at
the official wallpaper for the game
which you can download from the hogwarts
legacy website you'll be able to spot
floopers and an enormous acromantula
hidden in the forest